[Music]
you've seen the time Loop premise work
well for comedies horror or really
anything
[Music]
but it turns out when you try to
Groundhog Day an action flag that
usually kicks ass too
Edge of Tomorrow
before Chris McCrory made it his
lifelong goal to kill Tom Cruise on the
job Doug Lyman made a half-ass go of it
in Edge of Tomorrow the ultimate movie
for people who love Tom Cruise or hey
Tom Cruise I think I broke something oh
hold on hold on listen I can still feel
my toes
okay do it in this underrated Jam that
goes by Live Die Repeat on DVD but is
actually based on the Japanese manga all
you need is kill come on movie you've
got Mech suits Buster swords and a
tentacle monster embrace your anime ass
self now all you need is a mad scientist
who's there to do the exposition and
give you the heroes magic McGuffin they
can use to stick it into the alpha and
it Taps into the wavelength connecting
it to their maggot ah so does nay Tom
Cruise is William cage a member of the
Army's Elite corporate fluff Brigade
lost my advertising firm
here I am he's facing every American's
worst nightmare waking up somewhere
unfamiliar and everyone is talking
European
but when his face gets melted with alien
time goo he'll be stuck reloading from
the same safe State over and over again
watch as he gets a little bit better
every time at avoiding work
pitching his life story to strangers the
longer I talked more rational it's going
to appear the longer I talk the more
rationalist it's going to appear and
most crucially spitting game at Emily
blonde thank you hold on three
ah so close Okay one more Loop she's
playing Rita vertaski a strong woman so
even if she Saves the World Anonymous
dudes are gonna call her yeah what has
she done for us lately thrill at this
amazing character who gets zero
backstory except for her middle name
tell me your middle name
hey until the moment of vulnerability
where we learn the hidden truth her real
middle name
foreign
but honestly who cares Emily Blunt
push-up yoga plus a big sword shoot me
in the face mommy just wait wait I think
I'm okay it's funny because her day
doesn't reset she's going to prison
enlist in Humanity's war against the
mimic gimmick aliens who prove those
Flying Spaghetti Monster nerds were
right all along we'll throw everything
we've got at these hentai parodies of
Michael Bay's Transformers except for
using nuke's missiles artillery tanks
Jets or non-europeans instead relying on
crappy Mech suits with confusing
controls
oh
they'd run out of batteries in less than
a day
fall apart the moment you hit the ground
glitch out on the battlefield
and sink like a stone in water
okay who got the government contract for
these death traps Tesla
[Music]
all right
thank you
so get ready for an action thriller that
skips right to the good parts using its
time Loop premise as a narrative fast
forward button what next little uh PT PT
10 minutes because this is a training
montage disguised as a movie where cage
goes from regular slug to Super Soldier
faster than a sitcom actor joining the
MCU I'm not even trained for combat
[Music]
straight shot and even gets to plant all
of his elaborate heists off screen this
guy with the yellow armband always
recognizes you so just keep your head
down instead of my right but to be fair
if you don't have Ryan Reynolds whipping
your ear off the whole time these things
do go a lot faster
you don't have to do that I'm standing
right next to you now if Cajun read it
then somehow nail 24 hours of chunky
robot choreo huh okay go still blow up
the mimic brain and go back two days
earlier because because uh uh did I miss
the loop that explains the ending no
well whatever we win
story
Tom and Tom again damn this blunt hits
hard hmm forbidden Ramen That's it man
day over man day over my Tom can beat up
your Tom bad cheese of any Sharon The
Expendables and Tom Cruise when he
dreams about going to therapy
Alien War 80 Speed Run new world record
no wait let's see uh live die rename
Starship Loopers or how about Saving
Private dying wait wait nope groundhog
sleigh
your name is Nats your people
come on
Ford Skinner Griff this is only a second
time through the day and he remembers
everyone's name that's the most
impressive feat the whole film hey
screen junkies Tom Cruise dies thousands
of times in this movie but spits in the
face of death in Mission Impossible we
clocked the stats on all the Mi missions
betrayals kills Ving Rhames in a van
scenes and much more in a brand new
episode of by the Numbers click the Box
on the right to watch now
I fart therefore I am next time Gadget
next time
ah yes mad cat
Joe you're going to be a dad you are the
father